remember when you could order something
online and it would be there the next
day remember when there were more people
looking for jobs than there were job
openings those things were all the
result of efficient markets supply and
demand being in Balance but today
markets are out of whack in just about
every Market you're seeing a ton of
demand and Supply that just isn't able
to meet it I wanted to understand why
this is still happening more than two
years after the pandemic caused Mass
shutdowns so I spoke to some economists
and researchers it turns out that kova
didn't change the economy it pushed
forward and exacerbated a lot of issues
that were already there what could this
mean I'll explain
as we know markets function because when
demand Rises prices rise and that
motivates producers to increase Supply
but the supply hasn't shown up the auto
market is a great example
because new car production has slowed so
much Americans looking to replace their
vehicle are shelling out more for some
used car models than brand new ones but
at least with cars you've got a used
Market to buy from with some other
products like diapers baby formula and
toilet paper customers have just had to
go without them or wait I spoke with
Aaron Parrott a managing director at
consulting firm Deloitte he told me that
businesses aren't investing in supply
for a lot of products right now because
they don't believe demand will be
long-term and sustainable if it takes
more than a year to build out the
capacity parrot tells me that companies
would rather miss out on the potential
windfall because they don't want to take
the risk retailers like Target and
Walmart learned this the hard way
recently disclosing to investors that
they had to mark down billions of
dollars in merchandise because taste had
changed and Garvin Jay Bush Chief
investment officer for green Alpha
Advisor says there's another problem he
says companies were simply caught
flat-footed for years before the
pandemic they were too focused on
short-term profit goals and and didn't
invest sufficiently in emerging Trends
or research and development he points to
data that show in the Years leading up
to 2020 U.S companies spent more money
buying back their own stock and paying
dividends to investors than they did on
R D similar issues plagued the U.S labor
market we're seeing almost two job
postings for every unemployed person in
the country that ratio had never even
hit one to one in the years before 2018.
much of this has to do with what ADP
Chief Economist Nila Richardson calls a
mismatched economy where there are lots
of available workers but few with the
skills companies are looking for
Richardson says that because interest
rates were so low for so long and
companies could see their stock prices
rise without having to invest much in
hiring workers or training them many got
complacent now companies are looking to
hire lots more workers to help them
transition to the economy of the future
and finding that getting employees with
the skills they want is a tough task the
pandemic also caused many Americans to
rethink their work Arrangements because
of healthcare stories and the rising
cost of care the combination of health
and economic concerns the skills
mismatch and early retirements have
driven the percentage of Americans in
the labor force to the lowest since the
1970s even with nominal wages rising at
the fastest Pace in the years the big
picture is that covid made companies
deal with issues that many thought were
far off in the future today and even
though stock prices have fallen this
year most large firms are still flush
with cash and seem reluctant to rock the
boat the government hasn't been able to
step in to fill the void so the void is
just there the current environment is
leaving a lot of consumers without
Solutions and a lot of businesses
without workers but it does seem like
the tide is starting to turn adp's Nila
Richardson also told me that we're
entering a new economic phase it's not
recession or recovery it's Creation in
August the US finally had as many
Americans working as the country did in
February 2020. so the economy can now
create new jobs instead of just filling
jobs that were lost during the pandemic
and the creation economy could be a very
good thing rapper Denzel Curry has some
great advice he says pile up hella
Stacks when the bills pile up dollar
it's the only way to get the style up
that's all for now see you next time